lori lachlan turns 56 on tuesday and a
source tells e.t
she is spending her birthday with her
family as she awaits her sentencing
after pleading guilty for her role in
the highly publicized college admission
scandal we're just
a nice normal family you know like we
don't
we don't have anything outrageous really
happening
the source says lori plans to keep her b
day very low key
with her husband massimo gianouli and
their daughters 21 year old isabella
and 20-year-old olivia jade quote her
priorities have shifted since this
crisis began
and she feels as long as they are
together it will be perfect
she has been the face of this college
scandal and has taken
a huge hit to her career so at this
point massimo
and the girls are being very supportive
of her want to be supportive of
everything they want to do but i do want
them to have
somewhat of a normal you know finish out
of high school college experience maybe
because i didn't have that i really want
that for them the fuller house star
pleaded guilty
in may to one count of conspiracy to
commit wire and mail fraud
while her husband pleaded guilty to one
count of conspiracy to commit
wire and mail fraud and honest services
wire and mail fraud
after they paid hundred thousand dollars
in bribes
to get their daughters admitted to the
university of southern california
as recruits for the crew team even
though neither of them had ever
participated in the sport i just want
them to have that experience and get
that education
and have a degree to fall back on lori's
plea deal states that she'll serve two
months in prison
and two years of supervised release pay
a 150 000
fine and complete 100 hours of community
service
under mossy most proposed plea deal
he'll serve five months in prison
and two years of supervised release pay
a 250 thousand dollar fine
and complete 250 hours of community
service
e.t source says lori has not been doing
well as she awaits her
and her husband's sentencing on august
21st quote
this has been a long road and waiting
for their sentencing has been painfully
stressful
she is exhausted and is ready to get
past this point the source adds that
laurie's focus is to spend as much
quality time with her daughters as
possible and that the family is quote
doing their very best to avoid spending
the last days in fear of what's to come
i want them to be happy i'm happy to
guide them and get them up and running
but the source explains the actress does
have
one big worry about serving time in
prison what have you said to your
daughter
lori's biggest concern is that if the
girls need her while she is behind bars
she won't be there for them to help the
girls know she worries so they have been
making a big effort to show her how
responsible they are
overall i am happy and proud of my girls
and i think that they are nice people
and they are kind people and i think
that's the greatest compliment i can
give them
and despite everything they are going
through the source says the family is
actually doing well and lori is hopeful
it will make them stronger in the end